Man it's incredible.
Humans are humans.
It's incredible.
Like, fuck man I really
just wish people just wanted
to like each other all the time.
We could have so much fun.
We could have so much fuckin' fun.
Sucks.
We could have so much fun.
(hip-hop beat)
Coming to you live from Sydney, Australia.
Yo check out Opera House.
Got that Opera House out there like what.
That iconic building.
On my way to Melbourne right now,
gonna rip some fuckin'
Australian faces off.
I've been spending a
lot of time on mindset.
I don't like mindset
'cause it feels fluffy,
it feels a little too motivational speaker
and I don't love it but the truth is,
it fuckin' matters.
Because the reason it matters is because
it's the way you basically
approach everything.
One of the biggest reasons
I think I've been able to
build good companies is
I put enormous stress
on leaders, managers
of mine, to understand
that they're not capable.
If they are not capable of being
the bigger woman and
man in every situation
even if they are 100% right,
they don't have the
framework to be successful
as a leader.
This whole process real
closely and I've just been
really looking forward to connecting.
And if he chooses to 'cause I don't wanna
force anybody do anything,
the down times in his career to build
relationships and
infrastructure that lasts him
for the 50-70 years he
lives after football.
- [Helena] Hey Gary, Baben, I'm Helena,
I just met you at Sydney
Airport very briefly
before you guys got on your flight
to Melbourne and I sat
on that flight so hyped
that I'd run into you guys.
And then I got home and opened Facebook.
And so two years ago to this day,
was the first time I
saw any of your content
and it just before launching my own brand
and I need to say thank you for giving me
the confidence and bravado
to just be like, "Fuck it."
- [Interviewer] So you're
here for a couple of shows?
Just one show and off to New York after.
Yeah?
So you're in and out?
In and out.
What do you know about Melbourne?
I've been here three times on business
in the past when I grew
up in the wine world.
Yeah?
I know the people are fuckin' awesome.
(laughing)
And I know that there's good solid hustle.
A negative to you is crazy to me.
Insecurity at its finest.
It's just so stupid.
Why would you be mad?
You should be happy.
It should motivate you.
I love seeing people win.
Chris Sacca like crushing
the investment game
like during my era makes me pumped.
He deserves it.
He was right about the winner,
bought up all the secondary,
he was right about Uber, early as shit,
he was right about Instagram.
Like why would I be upset?
You know?
I love it.
- [Passenger] Raise the bar for all of us.
You know what the best part is?
It's like when you get into that mindset
when you love winning but the only thing
that you love more than winning is losing,
then you're fuckin' dangerous.
You're just fuckin', you've won either way
before you've started.
I love losing like 11 nothing in like a
one on one game as long as I know
there's more games to be had.
Like if AJ beats me 11 nothing
in the first of like five,
I'm like, "This is perfect."
You know?
I don't know, I just don't get people.
I just don't, begrudging is such a
flaw in stopping you
from getting to where you wanna get to.
You're putting out negative energy,
you're spending mind, you're
spending energy and time
on other people that are winning
who are gonna win regardless
of what you think.
Winners win.
The quicker you wrap
your head around that,
the more you don't spend any time on them
and you move and you know?
(laughing)
That's gonna be such a good line.
Gotta give a huge shout
out to Australian hotels.
They've been nice as fuck.
You agree Baben?
You've enjoyed 'em?
I have.
I think Zach Nadler has been a,
Zach have you brought value to the vlog?
Every day.
(laughing)
Okay.
I'm about to completely destroy the faces
of every single person
at this Melbourne talk.
I'm just not even gonna be fuckin' around.
Like I'm gonna go 11
instead of 10 tonight.
It allows me to start this talk
with something I don't really
talk a whole lot about.
I think I once quoted it on
Instagram but other than that,
I'm fascinated by people's need
to justify their ambitions instead of just
focusing on them themselves.
There's so much insecurity in this system
which is what leads so
many people to be fearful
to take the jumps that they want to do
because they're worried
about what other people
are gonna say about their failures
and I'm fascinated by that because
no question my biggest
strength was the self-esteem
that my mom put inside
of me and the environment
that I grew up with
and thick skin of being
an immigrant and not having much
and all the benefits that I had.
It is some kid you went to school emailed.
What?
Abel Franco who you got in a
fist fight with in middle school?
Holy shit!
Abel Franco.
I'm reading this and I'm
like "Wait a second,"
(laughing)
God almighty, this dude
was my super friend.
Super friend.
Want me to forward you that?
Yeah forward it.
That's one of my true fuckin' friends.
Abel Franco, this is
why the vlog's perfect,
Abel Fuckin' Franco, the best Abel,
what you don't remember and you remember,
first of all, it's terrible to hear
what happened to your
mom, I remember your mom
and I'm so, so, so
sorry, that's ridiculous,
I'm emailing you in a little bit,
what you don't remember
is I came over your house
for Survivor Series in sixth grade
and it was the fuckin' best and I remember
everything about it, you
were a tremendous WWF fan
and my core, me, you,
I'm trying to think of,
there was one other kid who,
oh, Regan, who died in a
car accident in high school.
I moved away as well, so did you but
I remember going to
your house and watching
that Survivor Series
like yesterday brother.
I'm so fuckin' pumped that you,
you just emailed me, I
can't wait to reconnect,
you know, there's not a lot
of people I fully remember
either from middle school,
back in the day in Edison
but you're one of them brother,
I'm so happy right now,
I can't wait to connect.
Is that literally you may make one,
make sure he makes like,
whatever story tell
but if there's not force
one hundredth of a second
of him in it, you'll shit how many people
will reach out to you.
You know what people don't know?
They don't get?
More people watch my vlog
than the far majority
of cable television shows.
People don't get what's
actually happening.
They don't understand that a cable show
has 37,000 actual watchers of their show.
They don't get it.
So you're gonna make like
a one second appearance
and like get hit up by like,
(laughing)
There it is, that's it, that's it.
I literally get emailed from like,
your fourth grade teacher Mrs. Thompson.
But it's really, really fascinating to me
of how people spend their
energy and their time.
So much of it is what I
would call defense work,
hedging against,
justifying, explaining why,
reacting to the market
instead of reacting to
what's going on in their own dome.
Third speech in Australia.
Saving the best for last.
The framework of how I attack the game
has so much more to do
with the way I feel about
my intent and how I'm going about doing it
and all these warm and fuzzy things
that I tend to like to talk about,
they're just strength.
Humility and empathy and
gratitude and all these
warm, emotional intelligence pillars
are enormous strength.
(audience cheering)
There's this huge disconnect right now
with entrepreneurship.
Let me tell what entrepreneurship is.
It's lonely, it's stressful,
it's difficult,
it sounds great on paper until you realize
when you have employees,
you work for them,
not they work for you.
So many people are built on one pillar.
Some arbitrage, some thing,
somebody's feeding them something
Facebook, Google, something's working
but it's a one punch pony.
And if you watch fighting,
if you like UFC or Boxing,
once somebody figures
out, it's every sport,
you can go from highlight
to fuckin' football,
if you have one move, when
the market figures it out,
you're finished and so
many of the business
and so many of the people
that I'm analyzing right now
have one move and they don't realize that
technology's about to take away that move
and they literally go from
hero to zero in heartbeat.
My friends, it is time to get educated on
what's actually happening.
My friends, if you do not deeply, deeply,
deeply understand how to market
on Facebook and Instagram,
please run the fuck out of here
and go to Google and
spend the next 400 hours
watching videos and
reading books and testing
because it is absolutely
the underpriced place,
I don't give a fuck
about Facebook or Zucks,
I could care less if it closed tomorrow,
I care about where you spend attention
and it's underpriced and
it is very crystal clear.
So please take advantage
of this incredible era
because if you do not, somebody else will
and that's gonna come at your detriment.
And the people here that
really go all in will have it
and the people that don't will feel it.
And to me that's why I
wanna come with this gusto
here today because to
be very honest with you,
I fully expect only 95%
to do nothing about it.
95, you're pumped now, this feels good,
I'm shooting the shit out of my energy
directly in your fucking mouth but
next Thursday's gonna
happen and you lose a client
or something gets fucked up
or you gotta pay some bill
and then you don't go on the offense.
And so I'm hoping for three or four people
to email me in two years.
I get it man and I've
heard that my whole life
and guess what, people
are just not executing
and it's so real.
You know, it's so hard to believe
something's happening,
when you don't see it.
When you don't feel it, when you don't see
and feel what I feel, I
get it 'cause there's a lot
of things in the world
that I don't see and feel
and then they happen, people are like
I told you that plants didn't have as much
protein as they used to, I'm
like, plants have protein?
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like I don't know, there's
a lot of shit I don't know.
But there's one thing I know
and I've known it my whole life.
I know what you're gonna
do before you do it
and that's why I get to stand up here
and I'm telling you right the fuck now,
Facebook and Instagram and Voice.
Bet your fuckin' children's health on it.
(laughing)
Thank you.
(applause)
I'm tired which is great.
You just killed Australia in 36 hours.
We did destroy, we did
fuckin' destroy Australia.
We sliced Australia.
Good trip.
Great to see ya.
We'll chat next week.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for such a, it was awesome fun,
it was so cool.
Alright guys, I know you've been
waiting this whole Australia trip.
I know you have Baben.
- [Baben] This is my first--
This is your first experience
where a normal businessman turns into
the world's greatest emerging superhero.
Airport Gary.
Superheroes of the 21st century.
It is officially Airport Gary.
(chuckling)
I love it.
(ambient piano beat)